[Music]
a fast spreading coronavirus sub-variant
threatens to bring yet another surge in
covet cases here to america the
sub-variant called ba2
is more contagious than the original
omicron variant and it is rapidly
spreading in parts of asia and europe it
now makes up about a quarter of cases
here at home and it could explode just
in time for spring allergy season of
course so some of those symptoms can
feel a lot like covid
dr celine gander is an infectious
disease specialist editor-at-large for
public health at kaiser health news and
she joins us now for more
dr gander thank you for being here
a lot of americans have immunity because
of a booster or because they had omicron
and a lot of americans are just done
overall they don't want to think about
it so with those two thoughts in mind
how concerned should people be
we are seeing an uptick of coronavirus
in the wastewater so that's your sewage
water so we know that there is
increasing transmission across the
country the real question is does that
translate into severe disease
hospitalization and death and that
really depends on if people are
vaccinated and boosted
if they've had a recent infection so say
over the holidays with omicron they
probably have some protection from that
and if they're elderly or
immunocompromised they certainly are at
higher risk so does it make sense to
lift the mass restrictions if you know
that there's an uptick coming
i think people should be aware just like
we saw on the morning news today the
pollen count in the community i think
similarly we should have maybe a
wastewater surveillance count as to yes
we're seeing this increase maybe you
should think about taking a mask with
you just like you think about taking
that umbrella now tony mentioned
allergies spring is here and for
millions of americans including myself
that brings those seasonal allergies how
do you know the difference because we
were at a point we were just talking
about this doing a commercial break
where a sniffle in public will get you a
crazy look from somebody standing next
to you so how do we know the difference
between seasonal allergies and someone
that may have symptoms the fact is you
can't tell the difference without a test
like i can't tell you it's not home to
see me
you need to take a test so you know you
can have the sniffles you can have the
cough you can have a sore throat it
could be from covid it could be from the
flu it could be from seasonal allergies
so if you have those symptoms just take
a test take a test yeah and how often do
you think you should be getting tested
i think it all depends on what your
exposures are what your risks are but if
you think you've had a high risk
exposure if you have symptoms absolutely
go and get a test
uh pfizer oh go ahead and if you test
positive do you need to quarantine do
you need to lock yourself up the uk
model is very different they don't have
to quarantine at all right voluntary
there so if you test positive or or they
leave it to your own personal
responsibility i don't like that like
the honor system yeah because i don't
think the honors system works frankly
well i mean
what is the new normal we don't really
know everybody has their own definition
exactly right well and the honor system
is the reality that we're living with
you know what would i say be responsible
don't expose other people that might
mean you wear a mask to work that might
mean if you can stay home from work you
stay home
all right uh pfizer and moderna both uh
asking for uh approval for a fourth
round of boosters former fda
commissioner scott gottlieb says this is
going to be an annual thing uh you agree
so with respect to the boosters we don't
really have good data to support uh 18
and over everybody getting a booster i
think it probably makes sense for the
elderly highly immuno compromised
certainly
and as to whether a yearly booster makes
sense it really depends on if covet
becomes seasonal because you really get
maximum benefit from that booster uh on
top of just already been being
vaccinated for about three to four
months so if it's a year-round virus it
may not make sense to to go with a
yearly boost julian i've seen people
with their arms fall falling i'm not
getting a fourth booster this is now the
pharmaceutical companies trying to make
money what do you say about that there
is a degree to that in terms of how
broadly they're trying to go with fourth
boosters moderna has applied for
everybody 18 and over and again there's
not data to support that broad of a
recommendation yeah it'd be a booster
for the bank account
there you go
all right dr again we appreciate it it's
a complicated new stage do you think
we're in that endemic stage yet the
emergency's over we are not endemic yet
i would say the emergency is ending but
endemic means your levels are much more
predictable and we're not there i see
the light though we're getting light at
the end of the tunnel we're kind of
getting there all right dr gunner thank
you very much appreciate it